it looks like a game
and it really is child's place since
every throw is a goal
the small brown balls that these women
are throwing into the big car valley are
so-called seed bombs
the balls contain plant seeds
an outer layer of clay protects them
from birds and rodents
when it rains the balls soak up water
and then the plants grow all by
themselves
the fertile plateau of the bekhar valley
used to be famous for its lush seed of
forests
a cedar tree even ended up on the
country's flag
however growing settlements and
uncontrolled deforestation have meant
that there is hardly anything left of
the original forests explains a
coordinator from the aid organization
salaam ladc
we never used to think about the
importance of
trees we might sit under a tree in the
shade but we never asked ourselves where
did it come from
who planted it
it was only through this project we
realized how much effort it is to
re-green a country
reforesting lebanon is just one goal of
salaam
the work here is also supposed to bring
people together who otherwise have
little to do with each other says batul
ibrahim who fled from her syrian
homeland to neighbouring lebanon 10
years ago
the women here all work wonderfully
together whether they come from syria
palestine or
lebanon we originally met through the
project
but now we're all like sisters
we laugh together we tell jokes
it makes the work easier
some of the women live in in formal
settlements others have a solid roof
over their heads like batur ibrahim from
syria
nevertheless she says life in lebanon is
not easy for her her husband is
unemployed and her daughter regularly
needs expensive medication
without the eight us dollars she
receives for each day's work the family
would have no income
this project is more than just a job
that brings in money
that i had
lebanon was once called the switzerland
of the middle east because of its wealth
in the meantime however almost 80
percent of its nearly 7 million
inhabitants live in poverty
the situation is particularly dire for
the more than 1.5 million refugees most
of whom come from syria
the high number has led to mounting
social tensions in the country
suzanne amki has experienced it herself
she feeds her family of five with the
money from the reforestation project
she's lebanese but her husband is
palestinian their children are therefore
considered foreigners
there's so much discrimination in our
country
even my children feel it
because of their palestinian father
they're not allowed to go to the local
school
i wish my children could grow up like
any normal lebanese child
instead they're excluded from many
things
and my husband isn't allowed to take
certain jobs just because he's
palestinian
nationality does not play any role in
the trees for lebanon initiative
the only condition for participants is
that they do not have another means of
income
because the project especially wants to
help those most in need
today the women are making seed bombs
for wild time and sisters
in addition to reforestation the project
also wants to plant crops that can later
be harvested
after sifting the soil the women add the
clay that will later form the hard outer
layer of the seed balls
when both are mixed the seeds go in
everything is then mixed with water and
needed
it's a sociable process
the group then sits together and shapes
the individual seed balls
[Music]
when the balls are finished they need to
dry in the sun for at least a day
and then they're ready and new life can
be created from them
and even when none of us are here
anymore i've done something good for the
future of our world
for today the women have finished their
work
[Music]
the project's aim is to release a total
of 600 000 seed bombs by the time the
reforestation project ends in august
next year
it would go a long way towards bringing
back the country's famous trees
you